Peter Samuelson as a producer and
founder of five charities for children
who are seriously ill homeless or in
foster care his 26 films include
Arlington Road wild tom and viv and
Revenge of the Nerds Peter has been a
member the nickel committee for two
decades presenting the award to grace
Sherman is Peter Samuelson I'd just like
to say in these dark times of exclusion
and bigotry what a proud thing it is to
stand on a stage as part of a member of
the Academy which leads society from the
front in inclusion and diversity
symbolized by the three golden people
here the two dads and their son
is even a resemblance great writing is a
thrill if you're a producer it lights up
your day our hero's journey begins in
high school when we meet a young man
there on a scholarship who is not just
clever in math but a genius in math
cleverer than his teachers more
knowledgeable than them he leaves
intellectually everyone else in the
school everyone else that he's ever met
far behind and the first overarching
achievement of grace Sherman's
extraordinary script numbers and letters
is that she gives life to numbers to
theorems to hypotheses to structures of
numbers and ratios we don't understand
what they are but they are beautiful and
we are in awe of a young man whose brain
is at the cutting edge not just of his
city or his time but who in 400 years is
groping his way to the solution the
proof of the Pythian hypothesis that has
eluded everybody including Einstein
going back as far as 400 years but but
but he's african-american he's black
this is our times and the law
enforcement judiciary industrial prison
complex gets him it gets him and it
pulls him into its cogs and his gears
and its wheels and he finds himself in
prison and he has a mouth on him his
intelligence exceeds that of anybody
else anywhere near and his antagonist is
the warden the warden is a big boorish
narcissistic
opinionated thin-skinned man
a petty Hitler someone who must impose
obeisance on everyone around him and it
drives him insane that there is this
prisoner who has a hundred IQ points on
him that has a whole interior life
working towards his proof of the
hypothesis in his cell with a pencil and
paper so the warden takes away his
pencils and our young man DeMarcus is
reduced to writing with crayons so the
warden takes away the paper and DeMarcus
has to write on the walls and the warden
takes the crayons away and DeMarcus has
to scratch his theorems on the wall with
his fingernails until they are bloody
and the warden repaints the cell in a
script in the hero's journey there is
the abyss it's the low point
it's the pit and one of the things that
is delicious and eyebrow-raising is to
see a truly great writer take their hero
to such a low point that you feel as
though they are checkmated there is
nothing that can be done to rescue this
hero and bring him or her back to the
light but this is where gray sherman is
already a great writer because she does
bring him back in the way she does it is
with love because Beth who knew him in
high school who has in her own way had
as much of a genius career as he was
clever and gifted in math she has been
gifted in literature a voracious reader
she has read every idea every piece of
history every philosophical point and
has sucked it all in and has become a
truly extraordinary teacher in her own
she has her doctorate in literature and
she teaches but she has never forgotten
that boy now a man and she volunteers to
teach English in prison in order to see
him how great Sherman then resolves this
young man serving decades in prison and
resolves it and brings him into the
light is an astonishing accomplishment
in writing this is such an unusual
script its characters turn and twist in
ways that we don't expect but which we
find deeply rewarding I have the great
honor to present this 2018 nickel
fellowship in screenwriting from the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences to grace Sherman come up here
onto this stage grace between the
statues it may be the first time but
it's not your last
oh wow being over here thank you so much
that was lovely thank you so much and to
the cast that was lovely as a writer
when you start a story you never know
what's gonna happen you never know the
journey that it's going to take and so
to finally hear your story come alive
your dialog come alive with real voices
and a talented cast is just amazing so
thank you very much I feel as uh as a
writer the pressures on for a really
good speech let's see I would first just
have to acknowledge Don Angie Nichol who
founded this and had the foresight to
understand the need and the value for a
fellowship like this and how it has
transition and emerged and grown for
decades is amazing and so I am just
truly grateful to be a part of that and
I finally get to say it like to thank
the Academy and the nickel committee and
everyone involved in the selection
process Wow I am very grateful he
selected my script
just in general just the determination
and the will to year after year seek out
unique voices unique stories important
stories that otherwise may go unheard
and so it's just amazing so I thank you
for that
and it's it's been incredible week I'm
having a great time the driving has been
interesting but coming from Texas to LA
but I'm having fun everyone involved in
getting us here this week and before
that Joan Chris Jacob everybody that we
did me did meet behind the scenes thank
you so much it's been an incredible week
so thank you and to my fellow fellows
and we're just getting to know each
other this week but thank you for the
advice inspiration the free rides around
town thank you
but truly I've been inspired by your
stories of determination and never
giving up so a truly gifted group of
people and I'm just very honored to be
sharing this journey with you so thank
you and let's see and of course my my
friends and my family everyone back home
and all those that came out for me those
in the audience I don't know where you
are but thank you and then those with me
all who were actually quite surprised
that I was writing screenplays they
didn't know but it's but it's like it's
like what do you say hi I'm a therapist
who wants to be a screenwriter so but
but anyways my Sharon Teresa Erica and
everyone else
oh my endeavours not just this you've
always been there and supported me and
when they did find out about me winning
this without hesitation showed up for me
change schedules changed appointments
flights in today out tomorrow literally
but but I'm so grateful you all are my
very heart and I value so much in my
life so thank you so much
and to my mother who is no longer with
us who would have been so happy to see
me up here who graced me with her own
spirit of creativity and and
storytelling so want to thank her years
ago and Texas and our single-parent home
far from Hollywood she bought me my
first screenwriting book and not knowing
anything about the industry or anything
just because I said I wanted to do it
she believed that I could so and so so
anyone watching this just like I was
looking youtube videos at watery how do
I enter this and wanting to be up here I
would just say never give up and that's
not just with writing with any dream any
dream just keep going and and never give
up and I'm just you never know what can
happen so I'm just truly grateful to be
here
and what can I say I guess with all the
vocabulary at a writer's dispensed to
make a great speech for this experience
it's I actually can't put it into words
so once again thank you everybody
[Applause]